In previous lessons, we covered testing principles and
techniques. In this lesson, we will discuss a
type of software process that is heavily based
on the use of testing. The agile development
process. Also called test-driven development. To do that,
we will revisit some of the assumptions that
led to the definition of the more traditional
software processes. The ones that we discussed so far.
We will see how, when some of these assumptions are
no longer valid, we can change the way in which we
look at software processes. And we can change the way
in which we look at software development in general. We will
discuss how this changing perspective, let's us rethink software processes
and make them more agile and better suited for context in
which changes are the norm and we need to adapt
fast. In particular, we will discuss two processes that apply the
principles of agile software development and that are commonly
used in industry. Extreme programming, also called XP, and Scrum.
[BLANK_AUDIO]